[Music]
afraid you're not accepting so the
average Enya turned her eyes that she's
like this looking for money you say her
body should be oriented each time Center
just go with it here what happened what
happened
practice reconciling the energy hey sexy
she shouldn't land the same way
[Music]
you see so you're gonna last
underneath all you get afraid protect me
Jesus interlocked you can't just talk
reconcile fear it's not an academic
exercise we said a situation up it'll
trigger some things to consciousness
that your individual cells will start
screaming at you that's your shower i
yesterday you need your deeper i the
consciousness that's part of that which
is greater than you and we mark it with
what you keep swarm
[Music]
videos
on the cushy which is where most people
feel it consciousness and then it came
on Oh check attack you see a good ride
to my shoulder then the movement whoa
that
that's why I'm doing that version the
arm bug trap fine I'll come inside the
circle
[Music]
when I do that it's going to be a
foolproof on the knife head and I come
on this trip I hit here leave it lock to
my body okay now as I turn him there
will be room or I don't have to change
my structure as we go around there it is
same side
whoa leave it there don't tighten it out
boom here you're out as he goes around
we see I'm moving down his arm then
around that way he follows it up now to
bring more backs up into the Kazushi
angle so if I leave this arm down there
if there's more towards the speed okay
so we're done here like this I follow
the sword you see it's coming up
watch the difference do that outside
this is unnatural move your swords too
late
[Music]
let's so that part of this up then I
check boom
breathe here there that's it same thing
setting up your problem
keep going can you see one yes you can
don't start taking a cami just the
energy you decide how fast you go up
consciousness presents presents good
serve yourself what do I get afraid
observe
[Applause]
so we had Chris if he won't come in so
when I shook like that okay oh I just
come in so then somebody was all afraid
so I'm going to just look at you guys
hello yeah yourself here
it's no fear it's not accepting so when
I come in and it's just for to reconcile
you see I'm doing different different
it's just energy okay but your fear is
taking you out of the art there's no
cheating here